hey guys and welcome to and you already
know what this is I was actually going
to record something else tonight I'm
like I've been basically wasting all my
time in Skype calls and all that I
decided to finally record something but
just before I get the stream I figured I
would actually do something unlike like
there's a couple of things I could have
done like rollercoaster can one is
something that I kind of wanted to pick
up and there's also City skylines which
I still have some videos of but in the
end I still feel like the the let's play
is the thing that I like the most at the
moment and today I've got some simple
stuff by the way this pier it looks like
absolute [ __ ] so that has gone in a
second
but today there is some work on some
facades over here now these are gonna be
quite different than the facades that I
had before the main thing was that I was
kind of going to a do you have like a
sort of cityscape Spanish style which
was mostly derived from the Madrid
pictures that I kind of got my
inspiration from and what I kind of
based everything on up until this point
but there were a couple of very
important discoveries that kind of led
me to adopt a more rural kind of style
in this area well for one it actually is
something that I've wanted to do since I
didn't really see it yet and I really
felt like if I don't have that in the
park somewhere I'm just missing out on
something but it also just turned out
that pets efteling sets has roofs that
are perfect absolutely perfect for
Spanish roofs so at this point I pretty
much discard its t4 ELLs
no it's TNS was a taper though no it's
TNS roof tile set that is supposedly
like I said that is used for Spanish
roofs but the only problem is it is very
bright it doesn't really have a very
good ending to its model and overall
just the pets efteling set textures are
less bright not as versatile so that's a
bit of the downside to it but overall I
just liked it a tiny bit more and with
that also kind of came the idea that
alpine village is the perfect set for
the walls for Spanish buildings so the
the main core I figured would be alpine
village with the
having those white stucco walls that you
know the Spanish / Mediterranean
buildings as a whole are quite famous
for and pair those with the ethylene set
roofs and that actually turned out to be
an amazing combination that as well as a
random little wall that I once made for
no apparent reason like I still have no
idea why I even made that never really
used it because I always figured it was
a terrible wall but it's a it's a
basically a wall with a natural stone
texture and that actually turned out to
be perfect for a Mediterranean stuff so
and yet that's kind of why I figured to
just give those sets a try after I kind
of messed around with it and saw it was
possible and see if I could just wing it
and get a decent facade over here if so
if that would happen I would keep the
facade and get more of this rural kind
of Spanish stuff in this section of the
park and if it failed I would cry in a
corner somewhere cut myself and just
give up on everything no I would have no
idea what I was actually going to do in
this area maybe a more cityscape kind of
style just like the other side of the
lake but that's something which I just
didn't really want to do in the end so
I'm actually quite happy that it kind of
worked out in the end I know that's a
bit of a spoiler I suppose I can just
say yes this this facade did work out in
the end I'm pretty happy about it
afterwards actually there's definitely a
couple of things that I might want to
change and some issues with it but
overall I just really liked it and it
sets the mood as well as having some
nice details though there is there is
one big butt but I should get to that
later in this episode it has all to do
with a one tower in any case for this
style I kind of just wanted to keep it
more simple as you see the facades of
like the city area are quite tense have
like many pillars and arches and all
kinds of interesting stuff going on but
the rural things I just wanted to keep
as much of the white walls visible as I
could without getting it to look too
boring so it turned out that some Main
Street windows were some shutters from
catfish Cove were actually quite cool
for that and to kind of spice it up even
though I didn't like have any of the
details like the pillars and arches that
I could get in there I figured that the
vise might actually work for that it
also kind of helps to get that more
rural look to it's like there's like
this it's like a bit of an overgrown
farmer's house like a farmer who doesn't
give a [ __ ] about this house and just
let's find grow over it or like some
farmer who really loves nature and wants
to have it all around him
and okay so because something stupid
like that and that was basically not my
idea but I figured yeah that's how you
can look at it anyway and the great
thing about this facade I must say
though and one of the things that really
did make it come out a lot better than
any normal straight facade could have
ever looked is the fact that it is
placed on such a tiny space and it has
that really weird kind of curve since
the path right there where I wanted to
built the facade is diagonal but it also
kind of curves into the straight path
with the Boulevard for a second it was a
really weird placement to try and build
a facade on and that is actually in the
end I think what makes it so good so if
you get like the different buildings and
with different heights but also
different placements there's straight
buildings and diagonal buildings and
they all some of the buildings just kind
of stick out more than the others and
that's just turned out to look amazing
in the end so yeah everything just kind
of seemed to be right for this facade
honestly so I can say afterwards that
it's actually been pretty good
experiment I suppose though the back
sides the back sides are definitely sell
something to look at these were just
very quickly whipped up to have
something on the backside I might want
to look at that later on though honestly
it is just the back side and what kind
of theme park would and all kinds of
details to a backside but yeah this is
pretty much how all of these buildings
are going to be which is also the one
downside and why I don't want to place
too many of them is that it it to me it
kind of feels like a one-trick pony
since I have finally found like the sets
that I really like building them with
and the way that I can really built them
in a way that I can get behind the
problem with that is that they're all
gonna look incredibly similar so I don't
want to get too many of them especially
not in one small area so
do you kind of want to watch out with
that and not place too many of them but
it should be alright in the end also
what turn out to be a very handy thing
over here is to just kind of place walls
in a sense that you can just plan your
facade beforehand so you can I think
they call this a mass study in like
architecture world I'm pretty sure what
I call it that I don't want to be I
don't want to seem stupid over here but
something like that just so you you
place basically the mass of what the
buildings are going to look like before
you actually built the buildings itself
before I actually apply any of the
details or anything that you really
wanted to have so you can kind of see
what the shape is going to be of the
building how much of an impact it's
going to make on the overall facade and
honestly I've never really done this too
much and I think that was really a big
mistake in the past since it really just
helps out a lot to build your building
blocks before you actually get any of
the details and to kind of see how that
is going to look in the end and here's
also kind of what I meant we like the
layering as you can see by placing those
very straight walls everywhere but on a
diagonal place like that it just creates
a bit amount of more depth and just a
more interesting facade overall and that
Tower is actually kind of the tower that
I was talking about when it comes to the
little issues I suppose I can kind of
just talk about that basically I got
into skype call with black diversity and
black outs
it kind of did like a private stream
thing just kind of build these facades
and just kind of ask for some feedback
kind of kind of and yeah eventually
started working on that Tower
and there was like heap loads of
different ideas and they all had to be
compressed into one good tower which was
an extremely hard thing to do and
overall I think I spent like two hours
trying to get the right pieces of custom
scenery trying to get that right like
top piece of that little church building
with all kinds of domes and pillars and
towers and all kinds of fancy details
but at that point I realized it really
wasn't going anywhere so I decided to
make some custom scenery make that
imported that's put it on there and it
still didn't entirely work and then I
was like three or four
hours of work deleted everything and put
it in as a simple rural tower with just
a simple Pat's efteling roof and that
was pretty much how that happened so
yeah sometimes putting effort into
something really isn't the best thing
sometimes it's better to keep things
simple in the end since I really do
think that Tower was best just kept
simple same goes for these these
buildings by the way they are really
simple when you look at it no real big
details or no really interesting shapes
when it comes to it it's really just the
overall composition of the facade I
think that helps it in a way also that
Spanish building that's one with the
incredibly bright orange roofs will be
removed at some point in future I don't
know exactly when but it just kind of
has to be gone yeah it's gonna be yeah
it's gonna be sad to see it go but it
honestly doesn't really work here it's
especially we like all of the things
place that I have right now
it really doesn't fit what I currently
have and overall it just it looks it
just looks bad I think so I'm gonna have
to remove that I'm still not entirely
sure what I'm gonna have there I might
have like a facade that's kind of
similar to this might also have just one
building but I'm really not sure when it
comes to that stuff and that's something
to see in the future in any case that is
all in the future see I'm getting ahead
of myself again this facade is basically
what needs to be finished right now in
the present and this was also some idea
from like that little brain at that
little brainstorming session on skype
figuring that I could get something like
this in just a tiny little porch looking
whatever you would even call this thing
so I could get some fun vines in and
flowers and stuff like that I definitely
think that it has helped a lot to get
foliage and on this thing though that's
also something that you'll see in the
future just getting these tiny little
details like this porch looking thing
and even exactly what those things are
called with the hanging plants and in
the future also some vines really did
help shape the look of the buildings
overall the vines which are coming at
this moment right now
yeah without the vines I think these
buildings really wouldn't have looked as
good as they currently do like I said
there's definitely a couple of things
that I'm not too sure about like the
windows what types of windows I used
what types of cornices I used some
courses are really a bit too fancy over
here especially those Main Street ones
for the rural buildings that these are
trying to be but overall I'm just I'm
just kind of happy about it yeah on the
end and this was just also aside from
being a way to get more foliage into
this thing into this building overall it
was just a way to get more detail onto
it since I couldn't have the pillars and
arches the fancy stuff it's just a tiny
little porch that that tiny little
canopy and other details you can kind of
just randomly add to buildings we're
supposed to help shape this area more
overall so yeah that's also a tiny thing
that being said I'm trying to give as
many tips as I can along the way but
like always I'm definitely not sure
about everything I built and if there's
any feedback like anything that I might
want to change or have to improve don't
hesitate to say that either don't I
probably have set this in the past in
any case I'm just looking for excuses to
round up the video all right I had to
round up the video all right since this
is the end of the video so thank you for
watching and I'll see you all next time
that was the worst outro ish thing I've
ever done I I'm very sorry
I'll try to do a better one next time
another case see you space cowboys